على كل حال سالنا الناس هل المال يجلب
السعاده ام السعاده تجلب المال
المال هو اللي بيجلب ساعات علشان بالمال
انا اقدر اشتري كل حاجه انا عايزها يعني
انت معك فلوس خلاص بقى انت هتشتري بقى كل
الحاجات اللي انت عايزها مبسوط بقى وكده
وممكن انا سعيد
كلمه حلوه ممكن تخليني سعيد عشان انت لو
مش معك فلوس هتبقى حزين فالفلوس هي اللي
بتاثرش السعاده نهائي تمام هو ممكن راحه
البال والحاجات دي كلها هي اللي تجلب
السعاده يعني بس برضو مش هننكر ان في يعني
البني ادم اي بني ادم هيحتاج المال
السعاده اللي بتجلب المال عشان مقتنعه ان
لو حد مبسوط وراضي باي حاجه في الدنيا
فربنا هيكرمه وهيرزقوه بالفلوس يعني المال
كده كده يعني
يا فرحتي ان هيكون معايا فلوس بس مثلا ما
عنديش صحاب اهلي مش موجودين حياتي مستعيده
مصرفها على العيا على اي حاجه فلا طبعا
السعاده هي اللي بتجري بالمال انا لازم
اكون سعيده عشان اجيب المال واعرف اشتغل
واعرف استثمر اعمل اقتصاد وبكده يجيني
المال لو انا مستعده مش هحقق حاجه
[موسيقى]